[Music]
so
[Music]
speculation about the title has been
going on for a long time but now with
cinemacon it was indeed confirmed that
the fourth matrix installment will carry
the title the matrix
resurrections in keeping with this there
was even a first trailer which was shown
exclusively in las vegas
so we must rely on eyewitness report our
summary is based primarily on coverage
from the outlet screenrant and the
hollywood reporter
the story is set in the san francisco of
the future and features a thomas
anderson who apparently has no memory of
the events of the past three films he's
undergoing treatment by a psychiatrist
who's played by neil patrick harris and
is diligently consuming blue pills as he
keeps seeing the matrix codes in his
surroundings
in a store neil then meets his companion
trinity whom he of course also doesn't
recognize
later a young morpheus shows up and
gives neil the red pillow whereupon he
follows a strange person with a bunny
tattoo through a mirror we assume that
this is the german actor max riemold
these opening scenes are immediately
followed by hard-hitting action and good
old matrix style including martial arts
slow motion and telekinetic powers
the trailer ends with neo meeting a man
in a suit who advises him to return to
the matrix all sounds pretty exciting
though clearly the question is when will
we be able to see the trailer looking at
spider-man no way home a secret trailer
can turn into a video available to the
whole movie world in no time all
depending on their respective marketing
strategy of course
we strongly expect a prompt release
after all the film will already hit
theaters on december 22nd
be sure to activate the notification
bell on our channel because the release
is just a matter of time
[Music]
you